i'm sorry do we know each other not yet
but today's your lucky day
and why is that because it's the day you
get to meet donna
and let me guess you're donna oh you
have no idea how donna i am
i will take a bullet for you and i don't
mean that literally
but what you do for me is when i need
something you give it to me
it's not just a one-way street we also
do some actual secretarial work
take a look at what i did with your
calendar their hot shot
holy [ __ ] why did you get that done told
you i'm not like every other secretary
i'm donna come on you know you've
thought about it
yeah i think about a lot of things and
you would
but i won't you're afraid you'd fall for
me oh please if anybody's falling for
anybody it would be you for me
sounds like a challenge when you are
never gonna get to take
why not because i don't get involved
with men that i work with
no it just occurred to me that you and i
don't work together anymore
yeah that didn't just occur to you no
it didn't do you know how i know that
cause you knew i'd show up here the
second you heard i quit why do you think
i have this in my hand
what are we waiting for for you to
figure out that it's time to come inside
come work for me what don't go to
skating
i took a job at my old firm
i was hoping you'd be happy i am
if this is about your rule no it's not
about because if i had known that this
was gonna happen i never would have come
over
why didn't you know that it was gonna
happen because i hadn't thought about
taking another job before
and when i did
i thought about who i wanted to take it
with look i don't want to find out what
kind of lawyer i'd be without you
you just made partner
we just made partner
i'll grab the can opener whoa whoa
that's pre-trial ritual we're making an
exception
i'll get the thumbtacks two dozen three
dozen oh going for the record
rick sorkin excuse me mr sorkin you are
five minutes late is there a reason why
i should let you in
look i'm just trying to ditch the cops
okay i don't really care if you let me
in or not
i have never thought about firing you
you took something when we quit the da's
office come clean right now or i'll let
you go not give it a minute's thought
i knew it you were in trouble
you had no right i don't care
what'd you do with it she did what she
had to do she gave it to me and the two
of you saw fit to fight my battles for
me
we did what you would have done for
either one of us
so get off your high horse leave the
woman along
we work because i've always known that i
can trust you
don't ever go behind my back again
you're welcome hey hey
i'm starting trial today i know you've
got five minutes
never started trial without doing our
thing well you don't have time there's
plenty of time
we don't have time
i'm sorry
for what don't push it
what the hell were you thinking i didn't
know how to tell you harvey i found the
memo is that so goddamn hard you don't
understand
it had my name on it i stamped it in
that implicates you
did you keep it from me four years ago i
don't even remember seeing it four years
ago then i don't give a [ __ ] what it
implicates you don't keep it from me now
i had never made a mistake like that and
i thought that i needed look
keeping it from me isn't a mistake it's
a decision
i wanted to protect you lying to me
doesn't protect me
it betrays me betrays you if i had told
you the truth
you don't keep things from me you keep
things from me all the time that's
because i'm your boss
well maybe you shouldn't be my boss
anymore
i did what i thought i had to do for you
and if you can't
just fire me
[Music]
had harvey specter asked you to bury
something five years ago
would you he wouldn't ask me to do that
that's not what i asked
if he did would you do it
[Music]
oh see you're pausing which means you're
hiding something no i'm not
see i think you'd do anything for him
and i know why
is there a question do you love harvey
specter
what do you love him
that has nothing to do with it has
everything to do with
why'd your last boyfriend break up with
you
miss paulson why'd he end it with you he
thought that i prioritized my work over
our relationship
your work he asked you to choose between
him and harvey
didn't he yes who'd you choose
harpy because you love him lewis stop it
is not that simple do
you love him yes or no answer the
question
louis you're with them all the time your
work revolves around them your life
revolves around them objection
badgering you don't have a boyfriend but
the one you did wouldn't share you
with your dinner please i just need a do
you love harvey spectre
do you love harvey specter that's enough
you just had to jump in there at the
trial didn't you you just
had to fight my battles for me yeah i
did that because the last time i saw you
you were pissed that i didn't fight for
you well congratulations harvey all you
managed to do is make it look like i
love you
oh jesus christ oh my god you think i do
i have actually never met such a
self-important donna
about that time you once told me i don't
care what i once told you
that wasn't what lewis was asking he was
asking if i love you and you wouldn't
answer
because he was forcing a yes or no
answer to a complicated question
i am not in love with you harvey
[Music]
what are you doing here i'm here to
deliver these
who are those for who do you think
they're for for you
for your dressing room thank you
let's go you're coming
you think i'm gonna miss your closing
night i didn't know you were a
shakespeare fan
i'm a downer fan
you know harvey you don't have to do
this i know you've got a lot going on
with the only thing i got going on
tonight
is you
[Music]
i told you i'd never let anything happen
to you
and i won't ever
so you don't have to have to feel scared
like that again
i thought you said you didn't do the
comfort thing
i didn't say i didn't do it i said i
didn't have time because i was so busy
saving your ass
i'm sorry i doubted you
[Music]
i'm sorry i snapped to you anyone else
ever loses faith in me doesn't matter
[Music]
with you it's different
i should go
why you know why
you know i love you dawn
what can i do for you harvey i wanted to
thank you
for what for 12 years
[Music]
come up to meet you
tell you i'm sorry you don't
know how lovely you are
donna don't do it don't fall on your
sword again i have to
no you don't we might not win you don't
always have to be the hero i'm not doing
it to be the hero then why the hell are
you doing it
because it's my goddamn fault
no harvey it's not
it's mike's fault just as much as it is
yours then why should i be the one to
throw him
under the bus don't you get it i am not
asking you to throw him under the bus i
am
asking you to believe that the two of
you are worthy of being found
innocent what if i can't do that then
you can march yourself down to gibbs's
office in the morning and turn yourself
in but i don't want you to do that
why not because i think you're worthy
[Music]
and i don't want to lose you yes
tell harvey how you feel what
i know that it's not my place to say
this but donna
i wouldn't be with rachel if it wasn't
for you and if i let you lose something
that might make you as happy as we are
and i didn't say something i would never
forgive myself
so if you think there is even the
smallest chance that you might ever want
to be together
and you don't tell him that soon
you might lose the chance to tell him at
all
good you're still here where's lewis
because i have some news and i think you
should both
the feeling i thought was sad
it slips through my fingers and i'm
trying hard today
i'm sorry harvey
i just had to know the memories
of a stolen play okay you want to talk
about what happened
let's talk about what happened because
if anyone knows about selfish it's you
you have some nerve saying that to me
when you know i have put you over me for
years
i don't care what you've done for years
you knew i was seeing someone and you
did that to me anyway
i told you harvey i needed to know know
what
our lines have been perfectly clear for
a long time
our lines are as blurry as lines can get
i'm the person you call at six in the
morning
or at midnight when you need someone we
smile we drink we flirt that doesn't
mean i want more well for the record
neither do i that's right i didn't feel
anything when i kissed you harvey
whatever i thought might be there
wasn't living
something happens
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
mistakes
i'm here now
what
i just wish i'd come to my senses sooner
it's okay i was worth the wait
done what do you say we give them
something to celebrate
wait what are you saying
i'm saying i love you and whether i knew
it or not i wanted to marry you from the
second i met you
oh my god donna roberta
paulson will you marry me right here
right now
okay of course i'll marry you but right
now our families aren't here and i don't
have a dress
stop you look beautiful we can do it
again for our families
but if there's one thing i learned from
my mom it's that i wasted too much time
first
not forgiving her then not admitting how
i feel about you
i don't want to waste another second
please will you marry me tonight what
about rings we don't have any rings
we can find one for me but i have one
for you
that's what was in the envelope
what do you say i say yes
harvey
yes
you make me cry
you make me crazy
but most of all harvey you make me happy
[Music]
without you i'm empty
i can never go back to the way i was
before
you've changed me and you changed my
life forever
i love you harvey specter i love you
donna paulson
do you have a specter take donna paulson
to be a lovely wedded wife
my dear do you donna paulson take
harvey's specter to be your lovely
wedded husband
i do then i now pronounce you man and
wife
you may kiss the bride
[Music]
and to add to the good news i just heard
from louis
the proud father of a beautiful baby
girl
[Applause]
and we will but right now i want to
dance with my wife
i found a girl
[Music]
beautiful and sweet
well i never knew you were there's
someone
waiting for me cause we were just kids
when we fell
in love not knowing what it
[Music]
was
[Music]
you look perfect tonight
[Music]
you